- I'm Eric Mason, I'm a mother,
and I'm a transgender guy.
Corey is my 15-year-old
transgender daughter.
I started transitioning
almost two years ago,
and Corey started transitioning
almost five years ago.
- I've always known that I was different.
I've always known that
I'm not the “normal” boy.
I was never like,
happy, I was always negative.
When I first put on some make
up, I was like... wow ...(gasping)
- My family is made up of me, my husband,
and my five children.
I waited, um,
until Corey was completely
through her transition
before I, I,
came out myself.
It was really hard keeping that secret
from my family, especially
from my husband.
But, at the time I just knew
I had to focus on my child.
- I've been bullied since fifth grade and
still getting bullied sometimes.
When kids said I should go
and kill myself, because
I was different,
(crying) I'm sorry.
When my mom came out I was
like, I'm not alone anymore.
We can actually understand
what we're going through
with each other, we can, you know, talk to each other
if we're having a bad day.
- Me supporting Corey
is, in my opinion,
what you're supposed to do as a parent.
You're supposed to support
your children no matter what.
So I don't feel like I did
anything special, I didn't.
I just love my kid.
I love my kid no matter
what she looks like,
no matter who she wants to be.
We are stronger as a family.
I think any time you are
living your authentic self
and you are living your truth,
it makes you a better person overall,
it makes you a better parent,
it makes you a better spouse.
My family is
everything.
We
fight, we laugh, we cry,
we're a typical family.
We just look a little different.
That's it!
That's all it boils down to.